you know what makes me feel like shit
naps life has no meaning but even more
than that I hate the way that books make
me feel sometimes I mean I don't know
about you but I want pretty big book
Wang I forget that I can't do the worm
you get it did you get the joke great
many book horror would be a more modern
thing to say you know they say not to
judge a book but it's cover
but I'll take my chances
how much and as much as I love reading
ultimately books make me feel sad
because I realize wow my life sucks or
if it's a Stephen King novel then oh
fuck that I mean cuz let's face it
compared to the portable fucking magic
that is books our lives are boring I'm
never gonna have an adventure even
remotely comparable to that of Rose
Tyler or Harry Potter
you fucking muggle it's like reading a
good book is the equivalent of taking
ecstasy and then living your normal life
after that is the comedown but I'd love
to hear your thoughts on books like what
are your favorite books which books make
you hate your life and do you have any
you could recommend to me that will make
me hate my life I actually actually
asked this question on Facebook a few
days ago so thank you so much to
everyone who gave me some book
recommendations oh yeah
Congress lost his balls he got neutered
this past weekend and he actually held
up pretty well he's not a stressed out
kitty
but his balls are gone so Zoey no balls
for you no belt
see you I'll see you next Monday and
stay awesome Gotham